ik Wil het heel graag hebben met jullie
over iets bijzonders
er zijn namelijk 6 schrijvers
die bij elkaar zijn gekomen
om 1 bundel te schrijven
waarvan alle opdrenksten
naar het Palestinian children's relief fund gaan
het gaat om de bundel schema
bibi selem heeft er onder andere aan meegeschreven
maar ook nog heel veel andere autoers
en britt die ik Ken via dvp
die helpt me het uitgeven ervan
de 6 verhalen die hierin staan gaan over hoop
en we weten natuurlijk allemaal dat dat ontzettend
belangrijk is
om in deze tijden te hebben
zeker voor de kinderen in palestina
de pre order
van deze bundel loopt tot en met het einde van April
ik HEB 1 linkje in mijn bio gezet
en als je dus dit boek koopt
dan steun je dus direct de kinderen in Gaza
en ik denk dat dat 1 ontzettend mooi iets is om te doen